bonjour jim bonjour jean marc germain on
vient parler de d'emmanuel jeune
emmanuel macron justement regardez cette
scène qui s'est déroulée mardi c'était
pendant les questions au gouvernement à
l'assemblée le premier ministre a été
obligé de démentir que sont mises
l'économie a cherché à lever des fonds
on vient d'en parler en vue d'une
éventuelle candidature sans excuse suivi
une explication vraiment houleuse sur
les bancs des ministres entre les deux
hommes
concrètement est ce qu'ils peuvent
encore coexister manuel valls emmanuel
macron au sein d'une même équipe
gouvernementale est ce que c'est
possible
en tout cas si j'ai bien compris la
teneur de la conversation je crois que
le premier ministre ait raison de
recadrer son ministre en lui disant tu
dois être à ta tâche tu dois être au
travail et si tu veut autre chose dit le
donc moi je soutiens totalement le
premier ministre et est dans son rôle
à ce moment là après est-ce que ça peut
dire ou pas c'est emmanuel macron de le
dire en fonction d'eux
du débat convient d'avoir sur est ce que
il est vraiment candidat est ce qu'il a
besoin de temps pour construire et pour
préparer sa candidature et si c'est le
cas il doit en tirer les conséquences
par rapport à son procès manuel valls a
eu raison d'eux bien sûr encore une fois
mais c'est le sait il est tout à fait
dans son rôle
vraiment ça et l'autorité c'est
important aussi
à condition qu'elle soit utilisée à bon
escient donc l'autorité par rapport à un
ministre en lui demandant d'être apte sa
tâche c'est à bon escient par 49 points
parlons maintenant un peu de françois
hollande
après paris et au la gauche vous savez
c'est ce fameux rassemblement des
ministres en soutien au bilan de
françois hollande
il devait organiser une réunion mardi
prochain à lille qui est la ville de
martine aubry finalement on a appris que
c'était fade le foll a annoncé que le
rassemblement ne naît pas avoir lieu
est-ce qu'il faut y voir une
contrepartie au fait que les aubry ce
n'est n'est pas voter la motion de
censure de la gauche contre le
gouvernement
écoutez je vais pas avoir de
contrepartie parce que c'est pas un
cadeau de pas avoir voté c'est
simplement nous avions réfléchi par
rapport à notre éthique qui vous ai dit
si j'avais pensé que ça avait pu arrêter
cette loge je leur ai voté je pense que
martin brahim aurait approuvé en ce sens
en revanche je trouve que c'est une
bonne décision d'abord cette affaire et
au la gauche
franchement c'est pas compris par les
français ce n'est pas au ministre ce
deux ministres d'être sur des tribunes
stéphane le foll c'est un peu différent
il anime un courant politique des amis
de françois hollande il peut le faire
mais qu'on ait des brochette de
ministres
à ce moment là vous allez les français
ils n'attendent qu'une chose en ce
moment de nous ministres ou
parlementaires c'est qu'on soit à la
tâche pour essayer de répondre aux
problèmes du pays pour essayer d'être
fidèle
autant que possible on a le droit de
s'éloigner un peu de nos engagements et
je trouve que c'est vraiment pas le
moment
surtout que ça inverse un peu les choses
c'est plutôt la gauche qui dit hey ho le
gouvernement et donc et au les
parlementaires aussi vous vu qu'on n'est
pas tous d'accord
je crois qu'il faut prendre ça comme une
interpellation à notre égard thivel a un
objectif c'est crédibiliser la
candidature de françois hollande en 2017
est ce que vous pensez que cette
candidature est légitime
je dirai la même chose que pour emmanuel
macron peut-être encore plus s'agissant
d'un président sortant parfaitement
légitime a présenté la cause sa
candidature mme en revanche ce que je
souhaite moi c'est que notre candidat
puisque vous voyez il ya des noms qui
circulent on a parlé aujourd'hui en a
d'autres qui vont peut-être s'exprimer
au mont beuvray
par exemple moi j'ai mes propres
préférences mais je vous en parlerai pas
d'en parler sur toi pourquoi je vous dis
ça c'est que yaqub comme je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure il n'y a qu'une seule
méthode pour trancher des désaccords
politiques au sens noble du terme
on a des différences de vue sur la loi
et les conneries il ya que le vote
qu'ils peuvent être tranchées ça en
démocrate la team et bien sûr notre
candidat il ya que le vote qui permettra
de dire quel est le meilleur candidat
que c'est françois hollande et manuel
marrero arnaud montebourg benoît hamon
et puis c'est s'il ya des primaires il y
en aura autant qu'à droite un des
candidats parce que des gens de valeur
il y en a qui sont pas très connu mais
il y en a autant que à droite donc la
primaire dit à l'adulte on enlève cette
prime un la primaire de la primaire si
possible avec les verts et les
communistes
3 si les verts les communistes disent
non la primaire comme en 2011 c'est à
dire avec une pluralité des candidatures
et un accès relativement facile à la
candidature avec des débats qui auront
lieu et avec un choix qui est fait par
toutes les femmes et les hommes
d'aguirre novembre vous venez parler
d'eux
de d'arnaud montebourg et du mont
beuvray en effet il sera lundi sa
traditionnelle ascension son rendez vous
politique qui pourrait annoncer ses
ambitions en vue de 2017
l'épisode de cette semaine sur 49 3
c'est une formidable rampe de lancement
pour lui finalement est ce qui peut
profiter de cet épisode
je sais pas mais moi je vais vous dire
la question d'une candidature la fronde
christian paul par exemple oui ils ont
des preuves limitées avec arnaud
montebourg mais moi je vais vous dire la
question des candidatures à ce stade
elle ne m'intéresse pas du tout parce
que je pense qu'on a à faire autre chose
c'est ce dont on parlait tout à l'heure
rck août c'est gauche se mettre autour
d'une table pour voir si on est capable
d'avoir un projet ensemble pour la
france et quand je parle des gauches
parler gauche politique
les communistes les écologistes les
socialistes et différentes tendances du
socialisme mais je parle aussi des
gauche citoyenne et de la gauche
politique parce que vous savez ces
mouvements type nuit debout ou l
initiative contre la loi travail et la
vigilance à l'égard des parlementaires
qu'à monter caroline de haas et commenté
caroline de haas et se fit binet c'est
des éléments très importants de la
politique de célébration que ces
fictions martine aubry pour les
prochains mois voilà et donc on a en a
expliqué hier qu'on allait cet été
proposé aux uns et aux autres de se
retrouver dans ce qu'on appelle un
carrefour de la gaude et gauchy vous
venez de l'écologie comment s'adresser
non on peut pas en dire plus à ce stade
parce qu'on en parlera quand ce sera
fait mais en tout cas notre volonté
c'est de contribuer à cette
reconstruction future des gauches merci
jean marc germain